you just did to me what politician is
doing they went away from the questions
so if you're opposing the most powerful
Democrat in the marketplace that you say
because they thought I was a joke like a
poison I titrated it I and it's like God
worked it wasn't me
we built up they thought it was a joke
they uses against Trump they kept
thinking they were winning and now when
the poison the truth is so strong when
the big dose hits them they already I'm
figure it out and so I'm just oh they're
on the globalist lethal injection and
I'm ready to die so let's just be clear
I've already won this is all gravy from
this point on so they are already in the
system I've already won and they thought
it was a joke and now they just took
their death to us really I'm gonna kill
the New World Order that's what they
called me violent it's all they hate me
I'm not physically hurting anybody but
the information is the end it's there in
two days
you think so no one can reverse it now
yeah I know it's true because humanity
wants to live and they're the ones doing
this i studied their papers i studied
their program and you asked why they're
so afraid they're so afraid because i've
got their number and i'm not afraid to
die so that's it